parce que j'étais dans ma télé et le
soir de Francky Vincent et le lendemain
et hier soir j'étais alors le soir de
Francky Vincent j'étais atterré mais
hier j'étais doublement atterré
heureusement il y avait Géraldine et il
y avait Gilles parce que effectivement
Francky Vincent aurait dit je suis un
milieu donné aucun problème c'est un
grand chômage parfois moi je regarde sur
Youtube des sketchs de données c'est un
grand chômage c'est mon ami c'est mon
ami je dis avec dinabeck j'ai aucun
problème mais il aurait dû dire c'est
mon ami et tout ça en revanche sur
l'antisémitisme je condamne ses propos
fin de l'histoire 10 fois vous êtes dit
10 fois vous avez essayé de lui faire
dire et 10 fois il a refusé de condamner
les propos sur l'antisémitisme donc mon
mon tweet il est très clair ne pas
condamner l'antisémitisme c'est adhérer
à l'antisémitisme point barre donc
Francky Vincent m'a choqué hier
avant-hier mais que le lendemain
j'entends Guillaume pardon mais ces gens
thon
heureusement il y avait Géraldine et
Gilles enfin pour moi c'est même pas un
débat comment on peut débattre sur pour
ou contre l'antisémitisme c'est
facilement imagine-toi c'est comme si on
avait fait du racisme pareil on l'avait
dit moi tu sais le racisme j'aime pas
trop mais tu le combat tu le condames
non je le condamne pas bah si tu
condamne pas le racisme c'est que tu es
raciste alors on va faire aussi bête que
ça il y a des moments où il faut être
assez binaire il y a pas des débats
surtout Guillaume je sais que là voilà
Mathieu a résumé la ferme et je pense tu
es pas du tout d'accord avec qui l'a dit
NON NON bah ce tweet il résume bien ta
manière de penser c'est-à-dire que si on
pense pas comme toi on est complètement
fou donc voilà c'est tout ce que j'ai à
dire le débat c'était pas pour ou contre
l'antisémitisme c'était est-ce qu'on a
le droit d'accuser quelqu'un
gratuitement d'antisémitisme alors qu'on
l'a piégé on l'a mis dans la merde
pourquoi on a piéger on a piéger bah
parce que on l'a non mais j'ai pas tout
le monde mais les questions
la théorie c'est que il a été énervé par
Gilles et par le côté censeur et
procureur et procès voilà et il a pas
obéi agile Verdez ça c'est c'est ça qui
s'est passé lui le bien sûr que si on
lui pose la question à froid aux
questions on va le voir l'autre ok bien
sûr que je condamne
de Dieu
Marie il était devant 2 millions de
personnes peut-être que troquer il est
très sympa il aurait pu dire à Gilles il
écoute j'aime pas ton ton mais
évidemment que l'antisémitisme le
racisme
la violence faite aux femmes tout ça il
faut condamner c'est évidemment qu'on
donne pas l'antisémitisme bien sûr mais
c'est parce que c'est pour ça que j'ai
dit je vais te dire ce que Francky
refuse de te dire tu m'as entendu dire
ça et donc
[Musique]
quand Guillaume j'entends a dit parce
qu'il refuse de dire qui condamne
l'antisém donc il est antisémite
dans une sauce
ni raciste
le premier c'est le premier là il est
nouveau Gilles Verdez Guillaume c'est le
mec le plus tolérant que je connaisse et
c'est le pote de Gilles Verdez c'est le
premier le traité d'homophobe il y a
quelques semaines sur ce plateau quel
rapport c'est facile d'être un son cou
il est à son téléphone et insulter tout
le monde de quoi tu me parles de sang
couilles
merde sur l'homophobie ça prouve bien
que c'est pas mon pote mais c'est pas
mon pote quand tu es sur l'homophobie et
qui dit une connerie je lui dis quand il
dit un truc intelligent
de quoi tu parles de mon film achat
l'autre jour tu vas sortir une phrase à
la con en disant ouais tu rallume
mais je suis obsédé par le mot sexualité
non je suis obsédé par l'homophobie par
le racisme par les violences faites aux
femmes mais toi quand on t'écoute c'est
arrêter de dire ça c'est pas grave
chacun excuse-moi excuse-moi
je te pose juste une question moi je
suis obsédé par Daniel Moreau est-ce que
c'est grave
non ça va ça passe non mais après
Guillaume c'est vrai c'est Guillaume il
essaie de comprendre chaque fois voilà
c'est ça c'est il est pas là maintenant
racaille en créant de sang couilles
parce que soi-disant tu mets tout
agressif bah tu me dis que je suis à 100
couilles parce que et toi tu es agressif
déjà mais parce que j'étais je suis
devant toi je suis devant toi je suis à
ton couille devant toi je te dis que
parler on fait on fait partie d'une
équipe on devrait être tous ensemble tu
es là tu nous insultes derrière ton ton
téléphone
viens m'en parler en face là
qu'est-ce que je fais là je suis là mais
viens m'en parler en face je suis là je
suis en train de toi dès le lendemain
l'antisémitisme
à propos de couilles
avec toi priorité au direct c'est génial
si je peux rebondir sur les coups ici je
veux dire hein parce que
on dit tu me casses les couilles moi
j'ai pas dans l'idée que ça casse une
couille c'est assez
mou moi je dis une couille même si tu la
tapes très fort par terre moi je la vois
bien rebondir
ce qui lui permet de retomber dans le
potage d'où l'expression couille dans le
ben voilà c'est tout ça alors c'est deux
vieux deux vieux ils sont sur la banc
public regarde un pitbull qui est en
train de se lécher les couilles
il pousse l'autre du coup il dit [ __ ]
qu'est-ce que je voudrais bien pouvoir
en faire autant et le tu dis bah vas-y
mais caresse le alors d'abord
il est con carnet